[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted
and its words sometimes simple and
sometimes mysterious
should always be studied carefully it
is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international
pastor doug batchelor hello listening
friends
would you like to hear an amazing fact
from sunday october 8th through thursday
october 10
1871 america experienced the worst
wildfires in its history
weathered conditions across the entire
midwest region
during the summer in the fall of 1871
produced
very hot and dry conditions on october 8
terrible wildfires suddenly broke out
across michigan
wisconsin and illinois holland
port huron and manistee michigan saw
significant damage and loss of life
the most destructive fire occurred in
and around prestigo wisconsin
scorching nearly 2 million acres and
claiming 2 000 lives
very few people are aware of these fires
because they occurred on the same day
as a much more famous blaze that filled
the newspapers
on october 8th the great chicago fire
claimed about 300 lives
while destroying over three square miles
of the city including
more than seventeen thousand buildings
no
it was not caused by mrs o'leary's cow
kicking over a lantern
a reporter later admitted to fabricating
this story
the actual cause of the fire was never
determined
when it was over in 1871 those fires in
the upper midwest took
nearly 3 000 lives and destroyed over
3.8 million acres
no one is exactly sure what caused all
of these fires to break out on that same
day
one theory is that the fires were caused
by meteorites or a comet
from the sky you know the bible talks
about fire falling from heaven
in the last days stay with us friends
we're going to learn more
on this edition of bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
bible questions
hello listening friends welcome to bible
answers live and as
you can tell from the title we do our
best to answer your live bible questions
you can call them in right now and the
number we have lines open
an acronym to help you remember that
it's 800 god
says that translates to 800-463-7297
not only can you call in with your bible
questions but if you want to watch the
broadcast from our studios
here outside of sacramento california
it's a suburb called granite bay
you just look at the doug batchelor or
the amazing facts facebook page and
you'll see us
streaming the program there and again
lines open good chance of getting your
question on tonight's program if you
have a bible question
my name is doug batchelor my name is
john ross good evening listening friends
and our friends joining us on facebook
welcome to
bible answers live and as we always do
let's start the program with prayer
dear father once again we are grateful
that we do have this opportunity to open
up your word and study
not only with those uh that's in our
state or our city but really literally
across the country and even in different
countries
and so lord we ask you a blessing on our
time together in jesus name
amen amen oh pastor you opened up
talking about
some incredible wild fires and
you're talking about wildfires that were
burning back in the 1800s
but of course it's kind of interesting
on our way to the studio this evening
uh the air is so thick here in
california with smoke
the sun has this this orange haze and
it's just unbelievable you saw that yeah
you can look directly at the sun right
because it's filtered so much by the
smoke
and for our friends across north america
you probably have heard about the
tremendous terrible fires
that are going through california oregon
washington i think even some in idaho
and i use this particular amazing fact
because
right now we're on the verge of breaking
the record this year for the
the worst wildfires in the history of
america in fact the worst wildfire
in california's history was two years
ago in the mendocino national forest
the southern part now the biggest fire
in california history is the northern
part
of the mendocino national forest not
very far from
our home up there we have a home that
our families had for about 40 years
and yeah it's it's burned right now over
700 000 acres
and there are over 3.3 million
acres that have burned and of course the
record was 3.8
million now the loss of life back then
in 1871 was
just terrible 3 thousand and uh so
you know fire i got stuck
you know you know the story three weeks
ago when these fires began
i was literally up in those hills when
the lightning strikes happened
or shortly after and um got stuck by
myself driving around at night
it was surrounded by fire and had
lightning strikes
on the road behind me that i had come
from and i couldn't go back and
i ended up having to go south another
way so uh it's pretty frightening i was
thinking
boy that'd be a terrible way to go i
didn't want to get stuck out there and
and become a statistic and
you can't help but think about all those
people
that have a misconception about the
punishment of the wicked
now people think as soon as a lost
person dies he goes to a place
down in the earth somewhere cavern that
the devil's
you know talks about down in hell and
they think the devil's down there with a
pitchfork and he's
he's cooking people but it's not exactly
what the bible says a couple of
misconceptions one is
hell is not down in the earth somewhere
it says in revelation 20 god
rains fire down upon the earth
and it forms a lake of fire and the
other thing is it's not
burning yet because jesus said that they
are
being reserved for judgment of the
the great day and uh and then
the duration people misunderstand that
as well
and so the idea you know the bible does
say that uh you know people are going to
be punished according to what they
deserve
but the idea that in 60 billion years
they've only
begun to burn is kind of a horrific
thought it's not
biblical if you'd like to know the good
news about hell
i know that sounds like an oxymoron we
have a free offer so many people have
been turned away from god because they
they think god is a sadist who's going
to burn people forever and ever and ever
for the sins of a brief lifetime there
is a hell
some people say there is no hell there's
no lake of fire that is not true
but there's some misunderstandings out
there we have a free offer
to clear that up we have a study guide
that's called is the devil in charge of
hell
and we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls and asks it's free as
part of our amazing facts
bible study series just call and ask the
number to call is 800-835-6747
that is our resource phone line and ask
for the study guide
is the devil in charge of hell and we'll
send it to anyone here in north america
if you're outside of north america we
want to encourage you to take a look at
a website that amazing facts has that
deals with the subject it's called
helltruth.com just simply
helltruth.com there's a lot of
information there and
as past that i've mentioned uh yes it's
hell is real
but there's good news god is a god of
mercy and you can even see
god's mercy displayed in the subject of
hell and the destruction of the wicked
so
we encourage you to take a look at that
our phone lines are now open we're going
to go to our first call caller this
evening we got a caller from brazil
marwan is calling from san paulo marwan
welcome to the program
uh good evening pastors it is a pleasure
to
talk to talk with you
my my question is about uh
well in the future uh
there are many many that believe that we
have some
dominican decree and uh
for instance christians could be
penalized
if if they don't follow that
for instance government could establish
dominican rule some domain kuru that if
christians don't don't obey
it they will be penalized my question
regarding that is
is there any biblical test chapter
that uh mentions that
more clearly that that will happen in
the future
yes yeah and i think another way i might
say that is
um you know are there scriptures in the
bible that tell us in the last days that
the governments are going to make
religious laws that will tell christians
what they can and can't believe well
we're already seeing some of that right
now there are states
and places in the world where you cannot
preach what the bible says
about a marriage because they'll be
saying well that's being insensitive
or it's hate speech and um
and of course you read in revelation it
says those that do not worship
the image of the beast cannot buy or
sell and ultimately there'll be a death
decree
and so just like you find and that would
be in revelation 13
and then you can read in the book of
daniel chapter 3 in daniel chapter 6
the government made laws telling them
how to worship
and that is going to happen again
according to the bible prophecies in the
last days
you can read what is it ii thessalonians
pastor ross where it says that wicked
one will sit in the temple of god
showing himself that he is god
ostensibly because he wants to be
worshipped as god
and this is one of the characteristics
of the beast power
second thessalonians chapter two verse
four that's right the second
thessalonians chapter two verse four
so to answer your question yes
there is
uh there are examples in the bible of
scriptures that say in the last days
governments are going to make dominican
decrees or
religious laws is i think what you're
asking
we do have a study guide that deals with
the subject and it's called the mark of
the beast of course revelation
talks about the mark of the beast we'll
be happy to send this to anyone who
calls and asks that number again is
800-835-6747 you can ask for one of the
amazing facts study guides called
the mark of the beast we've got michael
listening in a whole of
ohio michael welcome to the program
yes can you hear me yes loud and clear
okay uh god god bless both of you in
your ministries
i had a long exhausted conversation
today
with uh some gentlemen about health
and they're under the impression that we
as sda
don't believe in health and i exhausted
everything that i knew
and it was beyond reasoning with this
individual
so how would i for the next time
explain that that we do believe in hell
well we believe what the bible says and
we being christians
and of course the bible tells us in
revelation chapter 20
that the devil and his forces surround
the new jerusalem
and god rains fire down out of heaven
upon them
and it says it consumes them so
ultimately they are burned
you can read in malachi chapter 4 behold
the day comes that will burn as an oven
and all the proud and all that do
wickedly will be stubble the day that
comes will burn them up
jesus speaks of hellfire and
he says and i think it's in matthew 10
jesus said do not fear him who can
destroy the body
but rather fear him who can destroy the
soul in hell fire so there has to be a
hell fire
but it tells us in hell fire ultimately
body and soul are consumed destroyed
burnt up
that's matthew chapter 10 verse 28 that
you're referring to there
you know the study guide that we
mentioned a little earlier it's called
is the devil in charge of hell deals
with the subject and again the website
also helltruth.com
you might want to take a look at that
michael there's some great verses there
and i might find it helpful
what does the bible say on this subject
next quarter that we have is george
listening from
new jersey george welcome to the program
uh good evening pastors how you doing
tonight
good a little bit cooler in this
yes thank you a little bit cooler in the
studio this week it was
hot in there last week it's a little
cooler i don't think they fixed the air
conditioner yet
oh well anyway
my question is on luke 17 verses 34 to
37 that
same type of of um of
messages in matthew as well right as you
probably are aware of 24 somewhere
around there but it's always confusing
about who was taken and who is left
especially the part that says where lord
and he says where the body is
there the eagles will be gathered
together it looks like he's saying that
those taken are taken in destruction and
what's left of the christians but i read
something recently
and i'll see how you uh feel about this
where it said the eagles might be
symbolic of god's people
and that where the body is i don't know
what that refers to maybe jesus there
are the eagles so how do you interpret
that with that where lord question which
is only
in luke it's not in matthew right and
and of course
very quickly in luke when it says you've
got three examples matthew has two
examples luke says
two men in one bed one is taken the
other left two men working in the field
one is taken one is left and two women
grinding at the mill
one is taken one is left that represents
two kinds of people are asleep they're
in a bed
you've got the dead in christ are
sleeping it says they will awake
one to life one to death two kinds you
get the resurrection of the just and the
unjust
two women revelation says there's two
women the true church false church
one is they're both grinding grain
they're working with the word
one is true one is false and then you've
got two men working in the field jesus
says the field is the world they're out
sowing and harvesting the seed
you get the true and the false
missionary messages so
those are very broad symbols that jesus
is using
and they said you know one is taken the
disciples say where as
like you know where are they taken now
in the jewish mind whenever the children
of israel
disobeyed they were conquered and
carried away they were taken
nebuchadnezzar came and took them away
off to babylon
and when the children of israel were
good they got to remain in the land and
they were blessed
the bible tells us about noah and his
family
they were saved but the wicked the flood
came and took them away
they were taken away in judgment so um
you know it is a difficult verse and
i've heard good arguments on the other
side but
i'm of the inclination that it's saying
that the ones who survive are the ones
who are left
not the ones who were taken and then
when the the verse there were you
talking about the where the body is i
think there's a
there's a reference to that you find in
revelation chapter 19 verse 10
where it says and i saw angel standing
in the sun and he cried with a loud
voice saying to the birds of the heavens
i come gather together to the supper of
the great god that you might eat the
flesh of kings and the flesh of captains
and it goes on to talk about the
destruction that occurs of the wicked
and symbolically it's described
as these birds these vultures gathering
together
comes from the the idea of ancient war
where an army that was conquered the
dead were often left
on the battlefield and became food for
the wild beasts
yeah and that's exactly what goliath
threatened david with
right said i'm going to kill you and
feed you to the beasts and so that
would pretty well answer the question
george about someone who said the eagles
really are a symbol of christianity or
something and
it's a it's a symbol of judgment they
were unclean birds
in the bible but thank you appreciate
your question
all right we've got chris listening from
florida chris welcome to the program
thank you thank you pastors again for
taking my call
my question is from gospel of john
the question is somewhere in the gospel
of john
jesus says that god the father is
greater than
he yet is
in we know that jesus is equal to
the father right yes
so my question is when it happens
in a chapter 5
verse 1 through 24 when jesus healed
the man on the sabbath day and then he
argued
that the pharisees argued with him and
and he says that he does only the will
of the father
and that the father is greater than he
right
yes that's what he said something like
that yeah
i have no problem with that he says you
know my father works and i work too
jesus recognized the authority of the
father
as above his authority all through his
earthly ministry now keep in mind you
have two things happening here
one it does seem like there are
different roles between the father son
and spirit that doesn't mean they're not
co-equal
jesus is all-powerful he's all-knowing
and
and he's eternal uh as the father
but when he came to earth and i think
it's in philippians
4 pastor ross where it says he made
himself of no reputation
but humbled himself even to the point of
the cross
and so christ on earth especially he you
know he was in human form
he laid aside to a great extent his
divinity
and so that he could bear our sins so
yeah i believe jesus is saying that he
was subject to the authority of the
father but doesn't make him less god
that's uh philippians chapter 2 verse 8
he's the first you're referring to there
so thank you you know we do have a book
that talks about the trinity and i
address the the distinctions in roles
that you see in the bible between the
father son and spirit
and it's called the one god or three the
trinity
we'll be happy to send that to anyone
who calls and asks you can ask for the
book on the trinity the number to call
is
st louis 800-835-6747-835-6747 mike
welcome to the program
hey how you pastors doing tonight we're
doing good
it's a little smoky out here but
otherwise we're doing good
hey i i watch you on tv all the time uh
patch uh
pastor uh uh bachelor i was i watched
you constantly but um
you're on channel 25 here and say in the
city of saint louis
but anyway here's my question i guess i
didn't think you guys would call me this
quick
okay you got your question already
yes i do i wrote it down to
um here's my question did jesus christ
i didn't get my glasses on but anyway
did jesus christ's hair
turn white and he died of shock and i
have
two bible verses that i used for asking
that question
one was mark chapter 15 verse 44.
and it's a pilot marvel that jesus
christ was already dead
and then i have a second one revelation
chapter 1 verse 14
and of course we know that uh only the
apostle john was actually their
president the crucifixion right and it
says that jesus hair was white
and his eyes were red which is the same
as saying they could
have been bloodshot so i'm saying that
he actually died of shock on the cross
and his hair turned white
yeah you know that's a new one for me um
when you read in revelation chapter one
and it's describing christ in glory the
white is a symbol for purity i don't
think it's that he was
died from shock and when it says his
eyes were like a flame of fire
that means a light was coming out of his
eyes instead of
you know most of us we take light into
our eyes
light actually was coming out of his
eyes so picture you're looking at a man
and his eyes are like the
arc an arc welder i used to weld and
every now and then i'd forget to put my
hood down
before i'd start welding and i'd be
looking right at the spark when it
happened
boy it'll blind you in a hurry and i
think the eyes of christ
you know this the light coming out and
so no i don't think it's saying his hair
turned white during the cross
his heart was broken he did perspire
blood
and it talks about that you know he
evidently died of a broken heart because
i've heard that's one reason that
the water and the blood would separate
when they pierced the side and two
distinct streams came out
so you know he died from a broken heart
and increased
a terrible anguish but no no record
really that his hair turned white
you got anything on that pastor ross
yeah i think of course revelation is a
symbolic book
and uh we have a number of references
there for example that same chapter says
there's a
sharp two-edged sword that comes out of
the mouth of christ
obviously so it's symbolic and as you
mentioned white represents
purity uh but yeah it is true jesus
died a lot quicker than most people who
are crucified uh the two thieves they
weren't dead
they had to have their legs broken so
jesus did die
from an overwhelming sense of separation
from the father and i just said that he
died from a broken heart as some people
mentioned yeah and one more thought on
that mike that i think i'll answer this
for you revelation chapter 1 is also
quoting from daniel 7
when daniel sees jesus prior to his
incarnation
it says the hair of his head was like
pure wool
and it says his throne was like a fiery
flame so
this is uh this is before christ died on
the cross in daniel chapter seven that's
verse nine
so um i guess that first picture is
actually of the father
but um i think the father and son same
thing the wife
yeah thanks for your call mike we got uh
let's see sam you're listening in
wisconsin samuel welcome to the program
peace be with you pastors thanks for
calling
i have an observation pastor doug you
know you say you get so excited when you
see how precisely our
our lord works with his precision
and the tragedy we had here in kenosha
wisconsin with the riots and the death
and destruction i saw a sign on a store
during
after the riots it said no jesus no
peace spent
no right below that was no jesus k-n-o-w
no peace k-n-o-w right i'll point it in
those two phrases
and my question to you was gentlemen was
is there anything in the bible that says
when damascus is no more getting near
the end of prophecy
there are so we may have to take a
minute and look that up there are
several uh prophecies about damascus
and at one time damascus was you know a
leading empire fighting
against uh israel of course it is still
in opposition to israel today
here we are three thousand years later
but damascus is a very
old sis city uh naaman the syrian
was from damascus and i'm trying to
remember if it's the prophet
um is it um
naaman that talks about the fall nahum
talks about the fall of damascus
anyway yeah it was the capital of the
assyrian empire
and of course they did serve as one of
the enemies the assyrians
did conquer the 10 tribes of northern
israel
and damascus is described as judgment
coming upon
the ancient city but the city has
had different rulers over different time
periods yeah
there's a prophecy in jeremiah 49
against damascus hameth and arfad our
shame for they have bad news they're
faint-hearted
there is trouble on the sea damascus has
grown feeble she turns to flea
and so and then i'll kindle a fire in
the wall of damascus and it will consume
the palaces have been hated
all that happens and ezekiel i'm reading
on here he goes on
to prophesy the fall of damascus
now this is damascus when it was led as
the assyrian empire you know it fell
many years ago
and it was judged i think damascus was
conquered by
the um the persians
and the greeks and in the romans
so they were yeah they were conquered
many times
uh from the bible time i don't know of
any prophecy that says when damascus
falls
the prophecy will land or it will be
over
so anyway there i'm looking and there's
60 prophecies about damascus or 60
verses rather so
probably don't have time to go through
them all right now but hope that helps a
little bit
thank you samuel well pastor i'm looking
at the clock we have about one minute
before the break comes then
might be good for us to uh instead of
taking another call we're not done we're
going to be coming back after the break
but we do have something exciting
that'll be taking place next month
might be good for us to tell our
listeners about the revelation now
series absolutely there is a special
uh video presentation that's going to be
a live presentation
anyone in the country or in the world
can participate
it's going to be streaming right here
from amazing facts an evangelistic
program
we're going to go through the most
important prophecies in the bible in
light of what's happening today
it's called the revelation now and you
can sign up your home group
if your church is meeting you can meet
with a church church group
and we're going to also have the zoom
groups facebook groups
just go to revelationnow.com
revelationnow.com and you can join us by
the way
you can go through the whole series for
free and there are lessons and materials
you can download and there's also things
you can order if you'd like
but uh plan now october 23
through november 14 we're going to be
doing 2021
presentations on prophecy the most
amazing prophecies in the bible and
invite your friends if you want to do
some mission work
invite your friends to come over and to
participate in this
online bible study that's going to be
streaming here from amazing facts
we're going to take live questions from
people like we do now
but i'm sure we'll get a lot of
questions about prophecy and the time in
which we're living
so be sure and join us by the way we as
pastor ross mentioned we are coming back
for more
bible questions we just didn't want to
cut anybody short
and you can also check out the amazing
facts website we've got so much more
material
and our free literature there we'll be
back with more bible questions shortly
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever
and includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides
plus a bible numbers and symbols chart
and eight pages of colorful maps
this best ever bible gives you a
biblical cyclopedic index
words of christ in red chronology of the
old testament
along with doug batchelor's how to study
the bible feature and much more
call us at af bookstore to learn more
about it at 1-800-538-7275
the amazing facts prophecy study bible
stands apart from other bibles
giving you the same solid answers you
hear each week on bible answers live
order your copy today at afbookstore.com
or by calling 1-800-538-7275
what if you could know the future
what would you do
[Music]
what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past
alexander the great becomes king when
he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy 150 years in advance
cyrus had been named rome was
violent they were ruthless they were
determined
the gospel writers see his death as
a fulfillment of salvation this
intriguing documentary hosted by pastor
doug batchelor
explores the most striking bible
prophecies that have been dramatically
fulfilled throughout history
kingdoms in time get your copy today
available now on dvd blu-ray or usb
for more information visit kingdoms in
time dot com
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question
answered provides a clearer picture of
god and his plan to save you
so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life
call us now at 800 god says
that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live welcome back
listening friends
and for those who joined us in route
this is bible answers live you can call
in with your bible questions anywhere
you're hearing our voice
you can either do that online regular
telephone you can try and send
in your bible questions and
yeah that's what we love to do answer
bible questions we're also oh i was
going to say we're streaming on facebook
some people actually want to see and
listen you're the audio visual people
and you go to
the doug bachelor facebook page or the
amazing facts facebook page and you'll
see
our humble little studio you know you're
going to notice in a few weeks the bible
answers live set
is changing on the other side of the
wall from where we're sitting right now
we're finishing out the new amazing fact
studios
we'll be moving into a bigger studio
that will even accommodate
guests that may join us for the program
at that time but
i've been rambling pastor ross let's get
back to our phones
all right we've got patrick listening
from granite bay patrick welcome to the
program
oh thank you for taking my call pastor
doug
been watching your show since you first
started
well then you're older
okay and your question patrick
my question right now with
everything that's going on with the
unrest
would be the book of revelation
and there are so many but i could pick
out so many that i would i would ask you
questions on i could just go to
revelation
chapter 19 verse 11-14
okay we'll take a look real quick and
let me read this then
if that's right and i saw heaven open
and behold a white horse and he that sat
upon him was called faithful and true
and in righteousness he judges and makes
war his eyes were like a flame of fire
and on his head were many crowns he had
a name written that no one
except himself that i'm sorry name
written that no one knew except himself
and he was clothed with a robe dipped in
blood and his name was called the word
of god
and the armies of heaven clothed in fire
in fine and white
fine linen white and clean followed him
on white horses
now out of his mouth goes a sharp sword
that with it he should strike the
nations
and he himself will rule them with a rod
of iron i think that covered the verses
you were asking about
but um yeah so this is a picture
you know in the previous chapters you've
got
babylon is warring against god's people
then you've got babylon falling and then
you have christ
coming he's pictured as the word of god
and he's coming
as king of kings basically to judge the
wicked
and to redeem the saved and so this is i
think a portrait of how his word
ultimately is victorious
i agree i thank you thank you just
looking at everything that's going on
throughout you know the world right now
that is that has captured me
reading the bible and then looking at
everything
i just was reaching out
and asking for how you read that and
that's
how i that's why i'm seeing things yeah
you know there's
my eyes yeah absolutely there's a
um there's a story in the bible that
illustrates what you see in this verse
and it talks in chapter 12 of acts herod
is making war on the church king herod
and he kills
james he imprisons peter and peter's
rescued from
prison and herod dies at the end of the
chapter
and it says but the word of god
prospered and so it starts with great
persecution
it ends with the word being victorious
which is what you see in revelation
god's people go through trials but the
word of god triumphs
in the end good question thank you
patrick
we've got uh william listening from
michigan william welcome to the program
hello sirs how are you great thank you
for calling
thank you for having me okay my question
has to do with when jesus
went to the city of cycler i believe it
is and he encountered the samaritan
woman
yeah and and she referenced to him um
sir you being a jew why do you ask me a
samaritan woman
to get you some water and my question is
how did she know that he was a jew
um did they have um dressing
designations of what have you the
samaritan's dress different from the
jews or what have you i don't
this was one thing that's a very good
question i i read that and i wondered
the same thing she said how are you
because i hadn't spoken yet why would
you a jew
speak to me a woman of samaria well you
know uh the samaritans were
uh part and they go back to the time
when the assyrians kind of repopulated
the northern part of israel with some uh
of their people
so the samaritans they looked a little
different they were
semites you know the jews are
semites that's where you know if someone
is anti-semite it means
the jews are descendants from shem
and they were called semi so the
assyrians were also semites but
but there were differences in the way
they looked there were differences in
their language they had different
accents
they spoke a different language and so
you know the the people in israel in the
time of christ they all understood
aramaic they could talk to each other
but there was a big difference
i've got friends that are from australia
and we kind of look similar and
but i can tell pretty quick they're from
australia or england
or like pastoral south africa and um
and the clothing was different so you're
right about that they so she
you know there was obvious differences
and uh
there may have been something different
about the way jesus dressed some think
that you know he may have worn
some of the garments of a rabbi where
they had the fringes of blue
and she you know recognized him for that
as well but yeah she evidently knew
right off
he was not a samaritan she knew he was a
jew good
good question all right next quarter
that we have is henry listening from new
york henry welcome to the program
uh yes um
my question i have two questions but
they're very short
i want to know how long does it take no
to build that arc
and what language did julius speak to
speak what language does romans speak
okay
very good how long did it take noah to
build the ark when noah first gets his
uh invitation to build the ark i think
it's in the last part of genesis 6
and god said my spirit will not strive
with man his days will be 120 years
and so we believe that god gave them 120
years of mercy
which is basically the same as the
lifespan of moses
it's divided by 340s and
then you asked what language did the
romans speak like julius caesar
well they spoke latin and that was of
course you know the earlier primitive
latin
and uh today we've got many latin based
languages
english is a latin based languages
spanish is probably closer to it and
italian
but yeah they spoke latin
and many of the early church fathers all
read and wrote spoken latin
and another language that was fairly
common in the time of christ
was amongst the roman empire was also
greek was sort of the language of
writing
the language of education and that had
come through from the greek empire
and have been adopted by the romans they
say when alexander the great traveled he
took two armies
he took one army for fighting and he
took another army of scientists
linguists botanists
and um writers and teachers so when they
conquer people they would then introduce
they call it hellenization
they'd introduced the greek culture they
thought everybody it was superior and
everyone should
understand the greek culture and so yeah
it was a universal writing method so i'm
sure even julius caesar spoke some greek
we've got casey listening in sacramento
casey welcome to the program
good evening evening
and your question i am so humbled to
finally meet you in person
i've been following you for some years
and i
have a question i am a humble student of
the word
i am nowhere close to a pastor or
anything of the sort i feel my word
needs to be fixed so as i study i come
across a very simple
exodus 20. and i am
such a student that i would prefer you
to read
because i wouldn't do it as good a job
as you
the simple verse of our sabbath day
practice and what the lord expects
because i'm confused when i had
a discussion about well let me read
so i'll read exodus chapter 20 verse 8
through 11. is that what you want the
sabbath commandment
okay remember the sabbath day to keep it
holy six days you shall labor and do all
your work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord your god
in it you shall do no work you or your
son or your daughter or your male
servant or your female servant
or your cattle or the stranger who is
within your gates
for in six days the lord made the heaven
and the earth and the sea and all that
is in them
and rested the seventh day therefore the
lord blessed the sabbath day and
hallowed it
and so your question is casey are you
wondering what is work
yes because it led to so many
disagreements as everybody wanted to
follow work differently yes so
that's a great question how do you
define work what is the work that we're
not supposed to do
at the beginner i i had to ask all of
the followers
what is that definition then so in a
concordance we looked it up
and it says ministry
yeah well i'm sorry but the word work
there in the sabbath when it says you
shall not do any work it's not saying
don't do any ministry
because in
all shortly after exodus
gives the ten commandments they built
the sanctuary and god instructed their
levites did plenty of ministry
on the sabbath day they were still
offering sacrifices and
and doing ministry on the sabbath so the
word work there it's talking about
if you're a farmer you don't plow you
don't
harvest on the sabbath day if you're a
carpenter like jesus you never see him
in the carpenter shop
there was no sin in his healing people
are teaching people
on the sabbath day so those kind of
works of ministry are fine but it's the
kind of
regular work a person might do that is
income producing
now of course if you're in the medical
field you know there's nothing wrong
with
doing emergency labor of healing people
on the sabbath day but the regular work
you know the office work that people do
that should be laid aside it's a time
for a worshipping god
and you know i've got a book we can send
your free copy and it's called how to
keep the sabbath holy
if you like that casey the number to
call is just 800-835-6747
and again just ask for the book how to
keep the sabbath holy we'll be happy to
send this to you casey or
anybody that's listening just call and
ask for that it's 800-835-6747
as for the book how to keep the sabbath
holy thanks for your call our next call
is
olga listening in pennsylvania i'll go
welcome to the program
thank you thanks for calling
and your question yes um yes i was
listening to one of the youtube
christian programs
and this has to do with revelation 7 and
the four
angels that are holding the four winds
uh of the word of the world the four
corners of the world
and this person said that those four
angels
were demons but i i thought they were re
uh god angels so that's my questions are
they demons or are they
god's angels well i think they're good
angels because they're holding back
the bad if they were bad angels they
god would god would
probably not put them in charge of that
i think these are angels it is like
their guardian angels holding back
the bad things that demons want to do on
the earth
and um yeah i think that uh
the bible says the angel of the lord
encamps round about those that fear him
and these are angels that are like
surrounding the world
north south east and west holding back
winds of strife
and storms and tribulation well you got
any thoughts on that pastor ross
yeah and if you look at the rest of the
verse it says an angel comes clearly an
angel from heaven because he has the
seal of the living god
and he says to the angels that are
holding back the four winds of strife
don't let them go
until we've sealed the servants of god
so here you have the angels working
together
yeah it would have to be a good angel or
good angels holding back those
good angels are cooperating to get all
of god's people sealed
that's a good point next caller that we
have thank you call olga we've got
uh eva listening in georgia or evan evan
welcome to the program
or evan evans sorry
you there hey how are you doing here it
um so i'll try to keep this brief but i
have um
a friend and she and i have been having
discussions about the stay of the dead
and i've been using the amazing facts
resources to understand it better
but one of the things that she brought
up came from
second corinthians chapter 12 verses one
through six
okay and i've i've read over this
several times and i still can't get a
full understanding of what exactly
it's talking about and she's i believe
she
is honing in on verse four um but
overall
i don't have a good grasp of these
verses and i would just like if
sure if you could provide some clarity
on it yeah let me read this for us real
quick and that's
second corinthians 12 i'll read verses
one through four
it is doubtless not profitable for me to
boast i'll come to
visions and revelations of the lord i
know a man
in christ who 14 years ago whether in
the body i don't know or out of the body
i don't know
god knows such a one was caught up to
the third heaven
and and i know such a man whether in the
body or out of the body
i don't know god knows how he was caught
up into paradise and heard inexpressible
words
which it is not lawful for a man to
utter now
this is many scholars believe paul is
saying i had an experience
i don't want to boast but i've actually
been caught up to the third heaven
meaning
the presence of god you know the jews
had three
terms for heaven the first heaven is the
air around the planet
the second heaven is the solar system
where the stars hang you know the
space and sun moon and stars third
heaven is the dwelling place of god
and they call that paradise and so
you know that's why jesus told the thief
on the cross i'm telling you today
you will be with me in paradise meaning
up in heaven with the father
and of course christ wasn't in paradise
that day
because you read in john chapter 21 he
told mary do not cling to me i've not
yet ascended to my father
so paul could be referring to himself or
he's referring to another
apostle or prophet that had a vision
where he didn't know whether it was in
the spirit or bodily but he was brought
into the presence of god
you know in revelation chapter 4 john
says i was caught up in the spirit
and so john was taken to heaven also to
third heaven he saw these things
but he he makes it clear now john wrote
this after paul
so paul if he had talked to john john
would have said yeah i wasn't in the
body i was in the spirit
so uh but they saw heaven
and so i don't know what your your
girlfriend you're studying with i'm not
sure what her struggle is with these
verses
i i believe it's uh she focuses mainly
on on the separation
of body and spirit um how your spirit
and one
you know once you die that your spirit
will then go to heaven but your body
will rest here on earth
and then once jesus is coming or once
there's jesus second coming then your
body
and your spirit will be reunited uh well
when god takes a person into vision
they're still alive he can in their mind
take them off in division
that's completely different from when a
person dies a piece of them jumping out
and going around being conscious
indefinitely until the you know second
coming
the bible tells us that the soul that
sins it will die
and it tells us in the resurrection all
the souls of those
who slept it will come forth
and so yeah it's pretty clear that
people are
sleeping a dreamless sleep now you know
what confuses people
evan and this may help a little bit is
there's that verse where it says absent
from the body present with the lord
and i think that's second corinthians
too i'm not i forget sometimes
i'm getting old friends but um paul is
basically saying
that when a person dies and they're
saved their next conscious thought is
the resurrection for them it's
instantaneous it's a moment the
twinkling of an eye
if your body dies next time you're
resurrected
it'll seem like a moment for you you
have no consciousness of time
so but the idea that spirits go off
disembodied spirits and float around
bible doesn't teach that and proof of
that would be there are 12 resurrections
in the bible
of people who came back from the dead
not one of them
ever mentioned being conscious in death
no
no experience that they said that they
had in death the verse you're referring
to is second
corinthians chapter 5 verse 8 talks
about being absent of the bodies to be
present with the lord
which as you mentioned is the second
coming the resurrection
we do have a study guide called are the
dead really dead and it deals with the
subject of what happens when a person
dies and we'll
send this out of course for free to
anybody who asks the number to call for
that is 800-835-6747
and ask for the study guide other dead
really dead
we've got deborah listening in eugene
oregon debra welcome to the program
thank you so my question is
if adam and eve
were in the garden for an untold number
of years
before satan was cast out of heaven
and was allowed to go into the garden
and take dominion over the tree
and tempt them what was that timeline
well probably satan was cast out of
heaven before the earth was
created um it seems to be
that uh god actually made this world
and the creatures on it and who could
procreate in
in their own image uh we were made in
the image of god
and you know man was a very much more
powerful glorious being
prior to sin we've kind of degraded a
little bit we've not been involving
upward we've been sort of evolving
downward but
lucifer was going through the universe
and
you know he rebelled against god and
basically said my government would be
better
god did not destroy him right away but
he gave him some time
to test the other creatures to see where
their loyalty was
i think god warned adam and eve said now
there is a
you know there's an enemy a fallen angel
out there and he's not going to bother
you anywhere but that tree don't go near
that tree
and anyone who touches that tree will
die and i think they'd been warned
and eve was intrigued and she got closer
and closer and
eventually you know the devil he um
possessed the serpent you know later in
the bible the devils possessed pigs
and god possessed a donkey
at one point he spoke to a donkey so um
anyway uh and i i don't think they were
in the garden i wish i could say they
enjoyed it for years before things went
bad
but god told adam and eve to be fruitful
and multiply and they were perfectly
healthy
they had not had any children yet so
they probably weren't there for very
long
so i don't know deborah if that's
helping answer your question about the
timeline
i thought that satan was cast to earth
when
he was thrown out of heaven yeah i think
that he was
you're reading in revelation chapter 12
where it talks about satan being cast to
earth
that's looking back when when the devil
got adam and eve to listen to him
they surrendered dominion of the planet
and god said look
this is the only world that has chosen
to listen to you you are now
restricted to this planet he was cast to
earth but he wasn't cast to the earth
until adam and eve had sinned
and i think the verse you're referring
to is revelation chapter 12. yes
you know i think this comes up also in
the study called uh did god create a
devil
yeah about that and uh we'll send that
to anyone who calls and asks the number
is 800 800-835-6747
and asked the study guide did god create
a devil and you know pastor
i'm just thinking about a dvd uh
documentary that amazing facts did
uh cosmic conflict cosmic conflict yeah
i think it's available
on youtube actually just type in cosmic
conflict i bet it's the first thing that
comes up
right you might enjoy taking a look at
that debris deals with the subject
we've got linda listening in sacramento
linda welcome to the program
hi thank you i have a question
um i'm reading the little book spiritual
gifts
and and it talks about um
angels were engaged in a battle there
was war in heaven
and the angels were engaged into a
battle
yes how did they fight i mean you can't
they don't
kill each other in heaven and i know
i've seen
i've read where there's some angels with
swords
yeah but do they use the word of god how
do they fight
is there anything that's a great
question and linda and that's actually
something of a mystery
when we produce the video pastor ross
just referred to cosmic conflict we
tried to depict the angels in heaven
fighting
and the only thing we could find you
know it says that they in ezekiel 9 it
says they've got a
destroying weapon it does talk in
in chronicles about the angel of the
lord had a drawn sword
and so we gave these angels flaming
swords and it ended up looking like
lightsabers and
star wars but uh you know that it's hard
for us to comprehend what weapons do
angels use and do they wound each other
their spirits so it's some kind of i
think there's some things we just don't
understand about what would be involved
in angelic battles but yeah that's a
great question and you know what i
that's one i've got on my list to ask
god when i get to the kingdom
is exactly what kind of weapons do
angels use they don't throw grenades at
each other i don't know
it's the only thing we can find in the
bible is in garden of eden it says
an angel had a flaming sword yes and
then of course revelation 12 talks about
war broke out in heaven
michael and his angels fought with the
dragon and the dragon and his angels
fought
and they did not prevail so were they
pushed out of heaven we don't know
apparently it doesn't seem like they
were bodies scattered jacob wrestled
with jesus maybe they all wrestled maybe
it was the wrestling that just doesn't
say but they were driven from heaven and
of course
we don't think that the evil angels left
willingly they they had to actually be
removed evicted yeah that's right
so good question that's where boy we
might have to tie off this question well
let's get one more quick one in
all right we've got uh is it uh yolp
listening from edmond
washington yo welcome to the program
yeah thank you we got a minute we got
one minute so let's make it real quick
oh okay um what is the difference
um first resurrection and second
resurrection that mentioned in
revelation 20.
thank you very much you did a good job
uh you know jesus says and i think
pastor ross this is john chapter
10 the hour is coming which all that are
in the graves will hear his voice they
that have done good
the resurrection of life they that have
done evil resurrection of damnation
paul tells us in first thessalonians
chapter 4 the dead in christ rise
first that's the resurrection of life
and in daniel 12 it tells us
many of those that sleep in the dust of
the earth shall awake some to
everlasting life
others destruction so the first
resurrection
is at the beginning of the millennium
it's the resurrection of life
and at the end of the 1000 years you've
got the resurrection of judgment you
read in revelation 20 the rest of the
dead
do not live until the thousand years are
finished the referencing jaw
in in john is john chapter 5 verse 28
and 29.
oh good thank you yeah and um we have a
study guide on the millennium that talks
about those two resurrections
we'll be happy to send you it's called 1
thousand years of peace apiece
you will find if you go to our facebook
page we've got
and it's all archived if you want to
watch this program later
it's got the offer number there always
on the screen for your free offers
friends we are out of time for our
questions for tonight
i think we're going to start doing a
bonus question at the end of the program
and that you can email us don't forget
the revelation now website if you missed
the announcement we're doing an
international evangelistic program
october 23 november 4 revelation
now dot com we hope you can sign up it's
all free
and it'll change your life next week
we'll study
[Music]
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before
bible answers live is produced by
amazing facts international
a faith-based ministry located in
granite bay california
the statistics are grim millions have
been infected by coronavirus
thousands have died race riots have
broken out on streets
political tensions are at an all-time
high does the bible have anything to say
about the times in which we are living
hi friends this is pastor doug batchelor
many people are wondering
if the world's about to implode some are
fearful that global events point to a
coming crisis
unlike anything we've ever witnessed did
you know the bible book of revelation
actually speaks about the days in which
we're living now
and it contains a message of hope if we
would only listen
that's why i'd like to invite you to
revelation now
decoding the bible's greatest prophecies
in this multi-part series
i'll be sharing relevant truths for our
time from the last book in the bible
coming october 23rd to learn more visit
revelationnow.com
can't get enough amazing facts bible
study you don't have to wait until next
week to enjoy
more truth-filled programming visit the
amazing facts media library
at aftv.org at aftv.org
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material
all free of charge 24 hours a day seven
days a week
right from your computer or mobile
device visit aftv.org
did you know amazing facts has a free
bible school that you can do from the
comfort of your own home
it includes 27 beautifully illustrated
study lessons
to aid in your study of god's word sign
up today for this free bible study
course by calling 1-844-215-7000
that's 1-844-215-7000
for life-changing christian resources
visit afbookstore.com
if you'd like to enhance your study of
god's word visit our website at
www.amazingfacts.org
and sign up for our free bible study
course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at afbookstore.com
which offers thousands of inspiring
books dvds and more
to help you get the most out of god's
word to take advantage of the offers
you've heard on this broadcast
call us at 800 835 6747
or visit our website at amazingfacts.org